so this is positive
and we're going to start up here at the
top with the data scientist the data
analysts the folks that are actually
writing code
and many times their job is to create
insights and to share those insights so
let's start by going to the left here
and creating insights they're going to
be writing code they can use R python
they can use whatever IDE they want
either rstudio Jupiter lab Jupiter
notebooks vs code all within posit
workbench so posit workbench is our
server-based implementation of the
various Ides
and your data scientists are writing
code again in whatever language they
want so if you're with an R they might
be creating things like shiny
applications pins are marked down
plumber but if they're python developers
they might be creating things like flask
or fast apis streamlit Dash bokeh
applications Jupiter notebooks maybe
they're also creating quarto documents
which is one of our newest tools
so when they create content like this it
doesn't do anyone any good if they can't
share it with the people that need to
see it and that's the whole purpose of
posit connect our second tool within
posit team this is our professional
publishing platform and this makes it
super easy to share all the cool content
you see here with the people that need
to see it like your boss decision makers
maybe your yourself maybe your friends
or family you can share it with posit
connect
so for today's session we're primarily
going to live within posit workbench and
posit connect but there's also one other
tool we'll touch upon today and that's
posit package manager and it does pretty
much as it name its name implies it
helps control all those great open
source packages with an r and python
also any you know packages you've
created yourself within workbench and
connect so we'll talk about all three of
these tools today that again round out
pause it team